I'm how stand up going it's good man
let's hear a little bit come on don't be
the worst thing ever do some jokes bro
why some jokes do it now I don't buddy
but that was a banker he Blake do some
jokes I was like oh ok do some banking
you can depend on golf you guys have it
chambered shooter ready to go stories
brother no you're like this is what
sells then this will have to hammer him
out that doesn't work that's like saying
throw some light cakes yeah I'd [ __ ]
kick let me kick right now yeah
shared for is better let's kill no
problem ok I got a joke all right this
was the this is how you weren't it
wasn't directed toward you but you can
you could step in I've never I've never
I don't tell jokes when my stand-up is
you know but this is a joke that I don't
know anyone who does but you all right
ready all right let's see if you guys
dare you guys not to laugh at this corny
joke ready do you guys hear about the
worst magician in the world he's like
alright he gets up and he he basically
says I realize gentlemen I am now going
to have the strongest man in the
audience come up here with this baseball
bat right here dude got this baseball
bat let me show you guys how this works
Gang Gang starts hitting solid binds
pass it around you can tell it's a solid
pine baseball bat this gentleman right
here kind of huge guy comes up he goes
what's your name I'm sorry goes Burt and
he goes what are you doing goes pig
farmer knows how much you weigh 300
pounds yes Wow big man you gonna say
he's strongest strongest guy in my
County all right so we proved these the
strongest guy here you go here's this
baseball bat wait take this baseball bat
now I want you to hit me in the head as
hard as you can with this baseball bat
it's a long joke so Burt's like Burt's
like hey shut the [ __ ] up bro and Burt's
like yeah but if I hit you in the head
I'll smash your head and kill you
because they said to me I'm a magician
just take the bat hit me in the head
it's all right you can because I know
but if I hit you this is a real bat I'm
gonna literally take your a Taurus all
right for the last time I want you to
take the bat hit me on the side of the
head as hard as you can
so Burt goes all right you asked for it
fine all the crowd he just takes and
hits them as hard as you can across
blood goes everywhere he [ __ ] gets
knocked out they got a rush to another
hospital swelling on the brain
[ __ ] he's in a coma for four months
they got a drain fluid he's almost dead
he finally four months later he comes
out of it and as he comes out of it he
goes tada
don't ever tell that one how did you
guys not laugh at that coat ever this I
was looking at that's because I dare
tonight he's gonna murder Connie hey boo
you out of the Comedy Store for that all
right one more joke
no it's been on our bottom quick hold on
yeah obviously a really good one I dare
you not to laugh on this one ready what
did the snail say when it was riding on
the turtle's back see got him ah that's
a good job you got me okay cuz get it
the snail isn't used to going that fast
sure [ __ ] off man guys you know you
don't know though it's good you enjoying
it yeah it's great man yeah killing good
yeah it's going well all right oh well
brother this is scary
ah different scary than fighting for
sure but it'd be like like going into
fight if you know exactly what moves
that guy was gonna do like you're not
gonna be a scared like you should know
your [ __ ] you should know your set yeah
you [ __ ] up it's on you if you're
putting in the work tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]